foreign
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we're
careful boys today we have a very
special segment where we're doing a new
segment called job interview yeah we're
interviewing people to help save the
sinking ship that is just kidding news
right and everyone sees how I keep
firing people but they don't see the
good side of me of me hiring people and
then cutting their pay 40 so today we
have a new person who we are going to
interview his name is Jason Lee come on
in Jason
foreign
[Laughter]
all right brother so um why do you want
to work here
there's so many places to work in the
world really good places to work yeah
really good places a lot of job and
demands out there too after my first
part-time job at some me I got scarred I
never want to work in the Food Services
wait wait you didn't like show me somi
yeah What's your deal with somebody I
love that place
the customers man yeah oh yeah what's
wrong with them what was the worst
customer you had there's like there's
one customer like this entitled Karen
came in one time and she just like
demanded that we give her like
everything on the menu
and like for free yeah like make
everything on the menu and then she came
back later and then she was like
um like you guys [ __ ] up the order and
she tried to do that [ __ ] where you like
get the [ __ ] for free oh did she try to
con you she tried to call us and we're
like we can't do that for you because
that's not how this works and then she
like made a whole fit and I'm like okay
so the customer is always wrong for you
if we bring you on [ __ ] the customer you
do the customers wrong okay okay that's
a win for me that's kind of a good vibe
for it I like that [ __ ] the customer you
don't really like the company you know
why because I see that he was protecting
the business and he was like don't you
dare [ __ ] try to con us you son of a
[ __ ] you didn't cave that's good yeah
[ __ ] the customers okay cool did you
guys you think maybe you guys did [ __ ]
up the order pretty hard though yeah
yeah yeah how good was the order like
did you guys nail that possible I'm sure
there was like a few were just like you
know what [ __ ] this lady like did she
did she go like I want every single item
on the menu and then when it came out
she was like it's [ __ ] up how did that
how did it work like pay at the counter
right so she like the man that a refund
at the counter yeah because you got to
wait for it to come out after you pay
it's like we make this thing called
taiyaki's and like little like fish
waffle thingies nobody knows what
they're called everyone calls them like
teriyakis it's called fish waffles it
sounds pretty good but yeah what's what
kind of food is so me so me so me so we
have like ice creams right well like
it's not a week it's not work there
anymore this fish ice cream so it's like
we have ice cream you can get it in like
a cup and then they have like these
little fish waffle things that you can
put on top oh like the Korean uh they
call it and they're like yeah like the
fish with the like the red beans
and then they also have ones where like
it's not with ice cream it's just the
fish by itself and they're two separate
things oh so like one goes on top of the
ice cream with the open mouth yeah and
then one just is like a filling with
like chocolate it's an ice cream store
he knows inventory he knows how to
explain this no when when this happened
did your did the manager did the Karen
ask for the manager because they usually
asked for the manager nah she's just
like she just didn't want to like cause
any trouble like the magic wasn't even
there actually because she's usually she
wasn't usually there so what would
happen is she's like can I see the
manager what would you do
I'll be like she's not here that's a
good answer you should be like this
that's good you should be like this you
want to talk to the manager
what's up just pretend to be the manager
I'm gonna be manager she wouldn't
believe me I look like I'm 16. but you
can be a manager how old are you Jason
I'm 22. uh what would you say it's your
best quality which is your worst quality
my best quality
well you know what this kind of shit's
gonna happen to you on the job
this is on the job danger answer the
question Jason I'm a perfectionist
that's my worst but it's also my
strength
we're working at a business park dude
there could be noises there's gonna be
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens there's dogs coming
in the room under pressure all right you
know what I work good under pressure
I do what about if you're hosting the
show and all of a sudden you're like
about to start and all the cameras are
fired up and then the boss is like I
gotta take a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and he runs
back there and then we all have to wait
for 25 minutes yeah but you're all ready
to go y'all cameras are all ready to go
I'll make sure to bring them toilet
paper I'll bring a decoy Joe in and then
I'll run the cameras and then have them
come in later edit that in later so no
one knows he was gone he thinks on his
feet it's pretty so let's say Joe has a
diarrhea because he gets that a lot and
then he sprains both of his wrists and
he needs help wiping would you help him
hell yeah whoa so he hates customers but
he's down with the down with the [ __ ]
Services he has no self-respect that's
good no self-respect too this one that's
good bosses are top prize so how about
this one okay the whole group right
we're all just laying in and roasting
Anthony Lee right we're just hard laying
in them and Anthony looks pretty sad
he's and he's also a member of the team
do you join in or do you say hey guys
that's that's enough we got to protect
Anthony Lee like what do you do here's
what I do
I go in yeah pretend to be on his side
oh to make him feel a little better okay
for five years
I get real close with them yeah I like
where it's going I've become part of his
family I infiltrate good [ __ ] him up
yeah that's good he's our little mole
okay what as long as he's not fully on
his side then you could be on yeah
what position are you applying for yeah
any position that's available oh I'll
work my way up either way wow work your
way down around here pal yeah I don't
even know if there's a up I want my way
down so far I come out on the other side
okay that's good we like that we really
don't have an up or down position huh we
just have tasks I mean we also don't
even know that when we got hired either
true like do you know when you got hired
here when I got hired yeah no I have no
idea exactly I don't even know what
happened to me I don't think he wanted
this job we just said you're I'm in a
[ __ ] Vegas with us
but no one gets [ __ ] in here either
yeah that's true which is kind of a
bummer
I mean there was a there was a lot of
[ __ ] going monogamous OMG was here I
assume you guys were [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that's true that's not fun yeah
okay I get it because you're like
married and there's a title on it yeah
it's fun to [ __ ] your followers not your
significance are you Pro [ __ ] fans or
what
no honestly I I'm so against fans
because like
there's like this line where if you
don't draw it they can like cross it and
it gets kind of ugly and plus you're
under like liability for whatever they
do well because you got you got fans you
know how it is or like I make music
right and so I have like some because
I'm like I make like Korean music so
like like K-pop I got yeah I got some of
those like fans right and so if if I'm
not careful like she can bite me in the
ass you'd be busting in [ __ ] dude you
got kids everywhere what kind of what
kind of uh do you make like what do you
play an instrument you see yeah I like I
like play guitar I sing and I produce my
own stuff can you can you sing like four
bars from order tracks
right there if you want to [ __ ] three
three and a half bars is it missing a
lot of strings yeah it is but yeah
without with no there's another guitar
that that's oh you're gonna play with
the broken guitar fine let's oh damn you
got skills okay wow this is actually I
think it's an untuned broken guitar it
says missing the last trip yeah you
don't have
dude
get out of here
's trying to juice it first it's back
then this guy's greasing the wheels
racing for his buddy whose guitar is
that that's both mine I never play them
Joe why do you waste so much money on
[ __ ] it's not a waste look what's your
entertainment value
these two guitars guys I got two guitars
I never play them I know I don't play
them though dude that one looks nice
they were gifts God damn it okay okay oh
he's got guitar fingers six bars six
bars yeah you guys want to hear a sad or
like no no seven I want it uneven yeah
yeah upbeat upbeat upbeat oh they're up
to you whatever you think is something
to make me horny yeah something to make
Joe horny whatever that is okay are you
gonna improvising improvising
um like I can play chords and then just
like see Melodies okay how about this
how about
you sing a song try to tell Karen she
can't get a refund back well that's good
that's good that's good okay
[Music]
feels like I'm at a UCI concert
I'm at the quad in high school yeah yeah
UCI I go to YouTube yeah exactly it's
for the celebration is that what they're
yeah the anteaters and dogs I hate it
I'm sorry
[Music]
wow you're such a [ __ ] please get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Music]
experienced
[Music]
please get the [ __ ] out of here please
[ __ ] leave no seriously get the [ __ ]
out of here get the [ __ ] out of here
very nice also should say Parental
Guidance on that one yeah I don't like
that I don't like the cursing that much
I like the radio version yeah yeah
fudge infected Kidz Bop version so going
based off the music what was the first
porno you ever jacked off to
that's such it so it makes so much sense
to ask that
[Laughter]
start touching yourself yeah left and
right I think the first thing I ever saw
on internet was like oh I was looking at
Pokemon cheat codes right wait what I
was looking at Pokemon cheat codes right
and
um this was on the family computer and I
think I was looking up how to use like
the action replaying because I heard of
that but I was on like this shady ass
website and you know how shady ass
websites have like ads that randomly pop
up yeah sure it's not familiar with them
I was this young kid and this this
pop-up ad with just a bunch of like
[ __ ] and [ __ ] just popped up wow
I'm like that's good what what is that
did you know it was a body part I knew
it was a body part because um like
yeah I'm saying
they're winking at you I think he does
have a sister based on that laugh yeah
yeah yeah
one younger one of those don't tell them
this don't tell them that okay okay keep
that to yourself next time I saw this
[ __ ] and I was just like I didn't know
how to feel about it yeah and then it
like came back to me years later I'm
like oh that's what it was that was porn
it was a Diglett
so you just thought it was just body
parts on the banner yeah like there was
no sexual feeling on my brain yeah
because he didn't know yet yeah I was
just like oh like that's just a butthole
like I'm just here to download legal
movies what is this just is that what I
asked for where's your grow up
um all over the place so my dad was in
the Air Force and so we every four years
we moved around so I was born in Japan I
was born in Okinawa Japan sorry you got
to be a U.S citizen to be a part of this
company well technically I was born on
American soil the U.S space so I am an
American citizen Joe doesn't respect
that though I don't like Japanese people
yeah
yeah he's like that's a shame he thinks
it's a scam really and he's right but I
don't remember anything from Japan
because it was only two years and then I
moved to Korea and then we stayed there
for like four years and so that's where
like my memory started and like I was
fluent in Korean but I went to like an
American like elementary school and then
we moved to Hawaii so I was in Hawaii
for like four years dude cool what was
your what was the worst part and best
part about being a military baby oh like
never being able to keep friends because
like it kind of it was like a thing
where that's all you had to play music
made yourself happy yeah and kids kids
would be like disappearing and
reappearing you know like
like you'd have a friend the next day
they'd just be gone and you just didn't
question it no because you could be gone
and they could be gone you didn't have
Facebook there was no Facebook back then
we were like kids too so like sometimes
we'd just be at the playground like we
just have friends next day they're just
gone you're like you don't know if they
died or they just like went somewhere
else or if they were ever real
[Laughter]
best friends with right we're best
friends
next week he was gonna go and the last
time I ever saw him I'm just like bye
was he from the enemies Air Force
probably yeah did you try to re-connect
on like Instagram or Facebook or
whatever I never saw him again his name
is Chase and I don't even know if he
remembers me did you make a song about
him you should look for him in on online
I do have a friend that I do have
contact and filming with like we were
best friends we even took a picture
right before we left and then like I had
his dad's phone number and I for years I
was like should I call this number
should I try to reach out I think you
should call them get them hit him hit
him up and see if see if he needs a job
because we're hiring I have no idea
anywhere in the world right now wow like
who knows if his dad's even still in the
military actually he's probably in
Garden Grove or something probably I
mean there's a base in San Diego here he
might be there maybe so what's the
favorite part about being a military
base favorite part I guess I mean
we get a lot of tuition benefits like
for college there's a lot of time it's a
very mature reason yeah like and also uh
USA too baby we got to explore the world
too yeah [ __ ] best insurance company
on the goddamn planet is that right it's
really good insurance yeah well no the
rates
what do you really want to be and and
and like I know this is a stepping stone
job for you but what do you really want
to be like in my life yeah yeah don't
[ __ ] me you don't want to [ __ ]
come here and work just what do you
really want we know that these guys are
just [ __ ] stairs for you dude yeah
you're gonna walk on them to get where
you want to go you're using us
to get to where you really want and
hopefully you'll wipe your feet at the
end too oh yeah always right now I'm
kind of pursuing music like I was like
talking about I make music and like put
it on Spotify and stuff make music
videos but um I'm also trying to be an
actor so I go out and like do auditions
and like
you do know our film Department's pretty
much not existed right well if it ever
comes back up again I got you okay like
we said things go down here not up so
that that will not happen but we
appreciate the sentiment I think next
week all our cameras will be black and
white actually
[Laughter]
a minute
yeah I think I'm like
70 on a good day 60 it depends on the
keyboard too a lot of you guys need to
do a lot of training seven days you type
like this bro what the [ __ ] I actually
use the time like that and tell my dad
until eighth grade I learned how to type
like that I got a professional question
for you professional question since you
play the guitar
um and if a female body was a guitar is
the booby the top part the [ __ ] is the
bottom or is it the [ __ ] is the top
part and the booby is the bottom were
you here last time we did the interview
were you here yeah okay I'm just curious
sorry answer the question boobies would
be in the left hand that's the left hand
why and the [ __ ] because if you play
the [ __ ] like that actually no that's
that's a good question because like
would you flip it upside down usually
your left hand is articulate because
you're playing the string so maybe maybe
it should be the other way around so the
[ __ ] is up here yeah and they can ride
because then you get all the skills up
here all right I'm gonna use here
outside
and then and then you're using your
right hand to do the we're gonna get a
sexual harassment lawsuit this is before
we even hire anybody it's all consensual
it's all concession are you comfortable
with workplace sexual harassment
to me no toward the bosses towards the
bosses because it's pretty mandatory
it's mandatory for new hirees to
sexually harass me I'm sexually
assaulting you guys yes it's mandatory
yeah
talk about that juicy juicy ass yes or
objectify him four hours a week required
the other day the other day I did my
part and I was like Bart you got some
fat tits today we need to be cat called
that's pretty mandatory we need to be
greeted with the whistle we need to you
know there's there's a couple of
unorthodox things but it's just we want
a good work culture here a safe place
right so be unsafe makes you feel safe
so me sexually assault things like all
right we got all the [ __ ] out of the
way and like now now we're comfortable
now we can work this guy's really good
man I think the manager material I think
are you comfortable having your pay
slash 40 randomly what I think I my
brain did not process are you
comfortable having your pay slash 40
randomly it could be on a whip it could
be on a Saturday night yeah we have a
thing called sudden hotikiri right it's
it's just like
you'll like it I'll be I'll wake I'll
wake up one day just say you know what
you don't you don't deserve how half of
your pay let me just cut that your pay's
about to change drastically just real
quick but then the opposite happens too
where I'm just like
here's 10 grand just take it it happens
once in a great [ __ ] wine it evens
out yeah if it evens out hey I'm all for
it what if it doesn't even know if it
doesn't even out and I'll kill myself
okay okay good answer good answer so
last time we did this we had your buddy
Justice on here right so like what kind
of thoughts do you have about Justice
like do you do you think he's a cool guy
do you think you'd be a better employee
than him because we love a little
friendly competition yeah yeah yeah
you know what Justice he's like a
brother to me you know we haven't known
each other for that long but I've
noticed some smart
but [ __ ] him yeah
this guy's competitive I like it yeah he
has that competitive Drive what's your
take on the king just yeah have you
heard of them have you seen that merch
no have you bought their merch illegally
I don't know bootleg website yeah
Alibaba I've I've never maybe I have
some in my closet maybe I just didn't
know maybe I just have some kindness
merch but I've never heard of them
because that's one of the uniforms here
I know it doesn't look like we have a
uniform but for new hirees we always
want them to be a part of the company
spirit and they need to buy a bootleg
can't just t-shirt on Alibaba on Alibaba
or or a hoodie or swiss they have sweats
sweats and yeah we're a hockey jersey
yeah and that's just kind of like the
year like you know you know being a part
of the company is just standard and then
once after a year you can dress casually
because you know we're more of a relaxed
company so like
um but in the first year you're gonna
have to wear all bootleg and just
that's really cool you never heard of
them though yeah that is really good
that's a really glad I wasn't really in
like the dance community so even oh you
have to go way out of your way to know
who they are I was like I didn't really
know about periodic Deep dive to find
these guys it's not do you even know
periodics that's wonderful yeah I had no
idea he was like yeah I was like this
and I looked him up I was like wait he
was in that Bruno Mars music video yeah
their periodic is yeah yeah but you
really didn't know because they were all
monkey heads yeah you like you couldn't
tell yeah so you couldn't tell which one
was canned how could you do a better job
for just kidding uh news than can't then
can yeah because we're liking you a lot
I'm not gonna lie this is a great
interview this has gone really well
um we're thinking about moving you right
up
right up the lap right up we're gonna
make room for you really like you yeah I
actually can be out of here in about 30
minutes
we've known can for probably over 10
years really
s'more
so much more I'm honored yeah we like
you dude I could never replace cam
though he's he's so amazing oh yeah you
can no wrong answer that's a trust me I
know can I've lived with him he's like a
little brother to me you can replace
something a thousand percent you
wouldn't be replacing him he would be
eradicated
he'll be gone you wouldn't even have
shoes for you to film I'll learn how to
dance just to fill those shoes but I
can't dance for [ __ ] but that's okay
that's only dancing editors anyway yeah
we find we find we did we did a poll and
we don't need Desi yeah we would like a
musician more musicians would be just
like throw my own music in the video
self plug yeah yeah you know okay I
think I think we hired them anything you
want man dancing editor is probably a
huge mistake and we're like oh
but if you're singing you have your
hands focused while you're singing so
that's more that's more it's actually
like Vogue
oh [ __ ] well I can Dude the camera's
right there and he's like my bad and
he's like it still works and then and
then four hours later after we've been
filming he's like guys that camera
actually glitched out five minutes into
the news
all right all right uh I think uh we
have new hiri welcome to the team Jason
yeah
hey how do people find you on Spotify
look up pohon HOH y-u-n that's my Korean
name h-o-h-y-u-n you're looking up on
Google Spotify it pops up anywhere there
you go brother
[Applause]
[Music]